assalamualaikum greetings of peace to
everybody from the Dean show i'm eddie
host of the dean shown to everybody all
over the globe thank you for supporting
the dean show thank you for sharing our
programs thank you for watching the
program and hopefully you've been able
to tremendously benefit and God willing
you can help to help us take the Dean
show to the next level now we need to
get these programs out we like to market
it we'd like to continue the daily
operations we like to get more guests
there are so many so many things we'd
like to do but everything costs we need
to be out there educating the people and
one of the means is through the Dawa the
Dow are inviting people to the purpose
of life educating them clearing the many
misconceptions and how are we going to
do it if we're just chasing the dunya
and we're not taking on the
responsibility so the crater tells us
what the purpose of life is where my
Harlech lagina well in soluble dune I've
not created mankind except to worship me
one of the greatest acts of worship
along with the five pillars along with
being of noble character along with
being the best in society is following
the way the Sunnah of the last and final
messenger sent to mankind and all the
messengers they all did our they call
people to the way of life that was sent
by the Creator Islam submission to the
Creator not the creation and that
education is so important so we need to
educate the people we need to invite
them and all of this costs all this cost
so help contribute to running and
spreading this message and you'll get
the reward mandela allah hide in
Philomath led gt5 the one who invites
someone to good will have the reward
equivalent to the one who does it
without diminishing years so if you're
contributing to something good and now
somebody hears the message because you
helped support this program and now they
end up accepting islam they end up
spraying and their character gets better
and they live the purpose of life and
you contributed to it you get the reward
man come on now so ladies and gents
brothers and sisters contribute to the
cause contribute towards the Dawa the
education of humanity and you inshallah
we'll have a ticket by the permission of
Allah when you're working for the Dean
support
Nadine on the their judgment all that
all those good deeds will be waiting for
you inshallah we can get to Jenna by
doing what our crate has told us to do
and support in the dower so support the
Dawa support the Dean show contribute
and help us spread this message this
message a piece piece of choir by
submission to the will of God Islam
we'll see you next time tune in every
week to the Dean show follow us on the
Twitter on the facebook subscribe to our
YouTube channels and wherever you're
watching us continue to watch a same
time same Channel peace be unto you a
salami